c'est en 2002 que les portes de
l'assemblée nationale vont s'ouvrir pour
vous voici dans la joie d'une campagne
électorale
j'ai fait deux mille kilomètres en
voiture j'ai fait cinq réunions
publiques déjà on est sept en
préparation vous amuser à découvrir la
france si je rentrais chez jacques
chirac et jacques chirac ma vie la vraie
politique la vraie c'est aller au
contact du terrain c'est conquérir la
confiance des français sur les gens me
demandent tous les jours de venir leur
parler dans leur petit village
c'est une impression extraordinaire
dans vie de politique et personne ne
misait un kopeck sur ma victoire je me
suis battue comme une lionne et j'ai
gagné et j'ai gagné et moi je m'amuse
[Musique]